انفجار قويا دوا صباح اليوم جنوب العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم مترافقا مع تحريق
لطائرات حربيه كما افادها مراسل الجزيره
باسم اصوات لاسلحه مضاده للطيران في ساعات
الصباح الاولى
وبتحليقا للطائرات الحربيه جنوب مدينه ام
درمان تاتي هذه التطورات الميدانيه بعد
ساعات من اتفاق الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع على تمديد جديدا لوقف اطلاق
النار بينهما الذي تم التوصل اليه في
مدينه جده السعوديه
الطاهر المرضي
اذا يعني هذا بعد ساعات من تمديد الهدنه
والاتفاق اتفاق الهدنه الجديد في جده ما
الذي جرى صباح اليوم
نعم بعد ساعات او هذا الصباح كنا قد سمعنا
دويا انفجارات في جنوب الخرطوم وكذلك في
غرب ام درمان وتحقيق للطيران ولكن هذا كان
في فتره محدوده وقصيره ولكن الان استطيع
القول ان الهدوء هو الذي يسيطر على الموقف
في كل جبهات القتال في الخرطوم
يعني
يعني ما يشير الى الالتزام
بالهدنه كما اعلن ذلك الجيش السوداني في
بيانيا انه يلتزم بهذه الهدنه وكذلك قوات
الدعم السريع هذا الهدوء ايضا شمل او
ولايات التي كانت مسرحا للقتال في الايام
السابقه وهذا ما كان يرجوه كثير من الذين
يودون التنفيذ او تطبيق ما يختص به
القانون الانساني وفتح المسارات في كثير
من المجالات هذه الهدنه لربما تكون تختلف
عن سابقاتها باعتبار ان هنالك لجنه
للمراقبه مكونه من الميسرين لهذه العمليه
الولايات المتحده والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه على الرغم من انهما قد اصدرا
بيان في الفترات السابقه وقالوا ان هنالك
خروقات كبيره قد تمت في الهدنه ذات سبعه
ايام وهذه الهدنه الجديده ربما تكون اكثر
تماسكا هذا ما يشير اليه البعض الكل ينتظر
ان هذه الهدنه اذا ما تمازكت يمكن ان
تستطيع ان تنفذ ما وقع عليه من بقيه
البنود المتعلقه بالامور الانسانيه سواء
كان بفتح المسارات او ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى بقيه المحتاجين اليها خاصه
في داخل الخرطوم وان تقوم باعاده الخدمه
لبعض المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه بسبب
هذه الاشتباكات ويستطيع المواطنون الذين
يعني يتواجدون في مواقع الاشتباكات الحركه
او النزوع او الخروج من مناطق الخطر وان
تلتزم ايضا
المتحاربه بالابتعاد عن المرافق العامه
وعدم يعني تجدد الاشتباكات في هذه المرحله
تحديدا وكذلك هنالك يعني كثير من الاحزاب
السياسيه وكثير من المنظماتها المجتمع
المدني قامت بالترحيب بتجديد هذه الهدنه
بعد ان ساورهما القلق خاصه ونتيجه في وقت
او قبيل ساعات من ان تنتهي هذه الهدنه
وكان هنالك قلق بان لا يكون هنالك تجديد
ولكن هذا التجديد وجد ترحيبا كبيرا
واعتبره البعض يمكن ان تتماسك هذه الهدنه
وان تؤدي في نهايه المطاف الى وقف الدائم
لاطلاق النار والكل ينتظر ما يمكن ان تسفر
عنه الساعات القادمه اذا كان هنالك
مفاوضات نعلم ان هنالك مفاوضات بعد تجديد
هذه الهدنه لوضع شروط جديده
لتماسك هذه الهدنه او وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار
الطائر المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل
جزيره شكرا جزيلا لك